eh bien je vais vous parler de jean
pierre jean pierre qui a vu les
contrôleurs dans un couloir du métro et
qui est parti en courant qui est parti
en courant parce qu'ils avaient peur
peur des uniformes ils savaient pas
encore les distinguer savoir si c'était
des militaires ou autres
il est parti en courant il avait un
ticket dans sa poche un ticket pour
venir consulter au centre de soins où je
travaille comme psychologue clinicien et
où il est venu consulter pour des crises
angoisse les crises d'angoissé ou
notamment ses uniformes lui rappelle les
uniformes des militaires qui sont venus
le chercher chez lui à kinshasa qui
n'ont pas trouvé mais qui à la place on
trouvait une partie de sa famille un
frère qui a été tabassé une soeur qui a
été agressé il a réussi à fuir avec un
parcours qui a déjà été décrit comme
vous l'entendez vous connaissez lisant
la presse vous savez combien ce parcours
peut être difficile et bien quand il
vient consulter au centre de soins où ce
travail ce qu'il présente c'est ce qu'on
appelle habituellement un état de stress
post traumatique avec des symptômes qui
sont nombreux et dont je vais pas vous
faire la liste complète
mais je vais vous évoquez deux ou trois
symptômes le plus courant c'est les
troubles du sommeil
nous avons des patients à primo levi qui
viennent de tennis de turquie du congo
du sri lanka d'afghanistan de différents
pays quand on lit la presse
d'ailleurs on peut savoir dans quelques
mois n'est ce pas d'où vont venir dans
nos patients c'est des patients qui
n'arrive pas à dormir quand il ferme les
yeux ils ont l'impression d'avoir une
scène traumatique tatouée comme le
disait une patiente sous la paupière des
scènes qui reviennent
de celles qui font peur comme un film
comme une photographie on est présent
plongez au coeur de cette scène
traumatique
cette personne qui s'endorment à 1h 2h
du matin et quie deux heures après se
réveille en sursaut aux prises victimes
à nouveau d'un cauchemar qui n'arrive
pas à se rendormir
les personnes qui dorment à six parce
que la position allongée pour elle est
une position trop vulnérables les
personnes qui dorment à billets parce
que là encore en souvenir de ce qui leur
est arrivé
le fait d'être en pyjama par exemple les
met en situation de vulnérabilité
s'ils sont habillés ils ont plus de
chances de se sauver d'être moins
malmené par exemple c'est un symptôme
très récurrent mais on en a d'autres
aussi handicapant comme les troubles de
la mémoire les troubles de la mémoire
comme une femme qui m'a secoué lors d'un
premier rendez-vous ou rien qu en
listant les prénoms de ses enfants et on
en oubliait 2 est ce que vous imaginez
ce que c'est que d'oublier les prénoms
de deux de vos enfants
le travail a pu commencer pour cette
femme et on a pu ensemble trouver
pourquoi pourquoi ce que en tant que
psychanalyste j'appelle un refoulement
protéger cette femme les deux enfants
dont elle ne pouvait pas se souvenir
étaient deux enfants qui étaient
présents quand elle a été agressée donc
d'une certaine manière elle les mettait
à l'écart les sortez de cette scène qui
n'aurait jamais dû voir
voilà un exemple d'un trouble de la
mémoire il y en a d'autres
il n'a d'autre je vous donne un exemple
d'un enfant un enfant irakien qui avait
ce qu'on appelle un strabisme divergent
un oeil qui regarde
loin de l'autre les deux yeux qui
regardent le jour c'est un enfant qui a
été opéré ici en france par des médecins
et qui malgré l'opération
malgré une rééducation à chaque fois que
sa mère rentrer dans la pièce parce que
je la faisais entré à la fin d'une
consultation pour faire un point
comme je le fais à mon cabinet à chaque
fois que cette mère entrées malgré
l'opération
malgré la rééducation les yeux partait
chacun d'un côté et c'est un certain
qu'on a pu traiter accompagné quand on a
pu mettre des mots justement que les
mots puissent redevenir ce qu'il eu ce
qu'il n'aurait dû jamais cessé d'être
c'est à dire un moyen de communication
avec l'autre on entend souvent parler de
violence politique alors que c'est un
terme qu'on devrait déconstruire la
violence s'oppose à la politique et je
vous demande de retenir sa la violence
dont le cas de mes patients a souvent
attaqué quelque chose d'essentiel
c'est à dire quelque chose comme un très
identitaire j'ai été persécutée parce
que j'étais homosexuel
parce que j'étais partisan de mobutu
parce que j'étais appartenant à une
ethnie
parce que j'étais kurde par exemple ou
etc etc
mais c'est des traits identitaires à
chaque fois des traits qui me servait à
me mettre en lien avec d'autres avec des
semblables par exemple eh bien c'est
très identitaire une fois qu'ils ont été
détruits m'empêche de faire lien et on
voit comment cette violence peut avoir
des effets pas seulement au sein de la
communauté mais aussi pour nous pour
nous en tant que professionnel on est
souvent souvent empêcher de faire notre
travail notre opération
je pense à un enfant qui avait assisté à
l'enlèvement de son frère très violent
où son frère était blessé eh bien il
était ici scolarisés et à chaque fois
que la maîtresse lui demander de sortir
ses cahiers ou deux
de montrer cette voie comme les autres
il évoqué voilà les malheurs dont il
avait été victime est la maîtresse était
l arrêté à ce moment là elle l'épargné
jusqu'à ce que cet enfant a été adressé
justement et qu'on a pu séparer les
lieux et que j'ai pu dire cette
maîtresse qu'il fallait qu'il continue à
faire son travail qu'elle me permettent
de faire le mien et qu'elles soient de
la même exigence avec sept enfants
qu'avec les autres et c'est peut-être le
seul message que j'aurais à vous faire
passer c'est à dire que ces personnes
qui ont traversé les situations très
compliquées qui ont été des proies
partout qui ont occupé cette place
d'objets n'est ce pas commun comme un
semblable qui seraient dépourvues de
volonté comme un corps dont les autres
fait ce qu'il voulait eh bien ces
personnes pour aller mieux
je le dis en tant que cliniciens n'ont
pas besoin de notre compassion de notre
pitié ils ont besoin d'être considérés
comme des semblables on est condamné je
dirais réussir cette opération en tant
que citoyen là je parle je le dis en
tant que citoyen non pas seulement en
tant que cliniciens on est condamné à
réussir parce que ces enfants ces
familles qui arrivent ces enfants vont
grandir avec les nôtres nous sommes
comme on fait partie de la même ville du
même pays on doit pouvoir construire
quelque chose ensemble
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire les
accueillir comme des semblables et ben
justement ne pas épargner ne pas donner
comme on donnerait une pièce non ça veut
dire pour moi un engagement un
engagement en tant que professionnel en
tant que citoyen ça veut dire par
exemple chacun à son niveau
je pense à des professionnels qui qui
s'occupe de loger ces personnes là et
qui loge l'un de mes patients un enfant
de 8 ans avec son père qui change d'un
tel les hôtels ou les petites bêtes
oui des hôtels où les rideaux le toit
tombeau morceaux tellement c'est humide
et bien ils changent d'hôtels toutes les
deux semaines et parfois la distance
entre les hôtels ça peut aller jusqu'à
60 km donc c'est un enfant de 8 ans qui
a changé d'école cette année en 2015
2016 qui a changé six fois d'école
comment voulez-vous que sept enfants
investissent des liens puisque je
parlais des liens qui sont rompus par la
violence comment il peut investir
l'amitié le respect qui peut devoir à
ses enseignants investir un lieu comment
une famille comme celle que je décris
aux comptes tant d'autres
comment pouvoir transmettre des valeurs
des valeurs qui sont comme les nôtres
quand on pense aux valeurs fondamentales
c'est les mêmes comment ces familles si
on les accompagne pas comment elles
peuvent transmettre leurs valeurs
traditionnelles la cuisine si ces
familles n'ont pas le droit des cuisines
et dans ces hôtels le temps là encore
seulement un détail mais c'est des
choses qu'on devrait pouvoir prendre en
compte les uns les autres
chacun à son niveau pour que ces
personnes puissent aller au delà de
l'automatisme ne pas rester verrouiller
un place de victimes mais devenir comme
chacun de nous une personne qui a des
projets d envie un désir
merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]